[Music]  [Music]  what is kepler teachings louise  we will not think about ourselves  we will not let our emotions guide us  we do this for the many  she was called mother earth  we plundered everything she offered  all reproductive efforts failed for both  men and women  they want to prove that we can procreate  here  survivors i saw a child  not transmission none of this even  matters  why are you following me i want to help  you  [Music]  we waited so long i'm so pleased that  you're here with us now  [Music]  it's imperative now that we bring our  people  are they coming  [Music]  the human race doesn't need us to  survive  are you still with us blake  none of us should have come back  [Music]  you